this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace
check out Squarespace com /bi graphics
for a free tribe there's a link below
christian dior is one of the most iconic
names in fashion so Iconix that even
those with zero fashion sense of heard
of him his most popular line is arguably
the equally famous miss dior and while
everyone's heard of the floral perfume
not everyone knows that there was a very
real miss dior
and her first name was Catherine the
perfume was launched in 1947 and when
Christian Dior wrote his autobiography
just a few years later he said the name
came to him in a moment of inspiration
when he heard his great mentor greet his
sister with the words voila
misty or in a way it was a fitting honor
catherine was by all accounts one of her
brother's biggest supporters but on the
other hands she was perhaps the last
person one might think would lend their
name to a perfume her contemporaries
knew her more for her unconventional
nature and when push came to shove her
fighting spirit she was born in 1917 and
as a young woman living in France during
World War two while that fight and
determination it served her well by the
time the war came to a close she would
become a highly decorated member of the
French Resistance even though she would
spend those final dark days as a
prisoner in a concentration camp
[Music]
the lives and the work of both Christian
Dior and his sister would have one
consistent theme a love of flowers and
gardening garnered from their mother
Madeline the family's early years were
peaceful by Dilek even the Dior
Patriarchate provided well for his
growing family accumulating a certain
amount of wealth as a producer of
fertilizer they were well-off enough to
keep more than one home but the one they
remembered most fondly was a family home
called Villa Arun in Granville the
beautiful seaside resort town in
Normandy that was just a second home by
the time catherine was born in 1917 and
for most of the time the family still
lived in Paris still the young dear
sibling said their childhood shaped by
the extensive gardens and flowers they
remembered their mother patiently
growing and cultivating an influence
that would become evident in later years
not all good things seemed to last
though and this was certainly true for
Dior's
Christian in particular was of a
superstitious nature and would later
recall the very instant the tide of
their lives began to change the moment
that a mirror fell to the floor in their
empty house and shattered misfortune
came into our hitherto happy and
sheltered family immediately he would
write one of their brothers grew ill and
their mother suddenly faded away and
died of grief Christian would remember
brother Bernard would be committed to an
institution where he would live until
his death until 1960 and suddenly the
well-fed enjoyed for a long time was
gone the Dior patriarch lost everything
in the stock market crash of 1929
further Christians modernist art gallery
went bankrupt amidst it all he found
himself caring for his siblings
including his favorite Catherine the
family moved to a small piece of
property in Kalyan an area appropriately
well-known for growing the flowers that
supply France's perfume industry it was
there that Christian began drawing
selling his sketches to help support his
family and finally heading to Paris to
enter the design world for the first
time Catherine followed him in 1936 and
worked at a nearby boutique it was their
first foray into the adult world into
the realm of Parisian fashion and
Industry but again the good times they
were not to last what was lingering on
the edge of everyone's minds and by 1939
businesses were closing as
prepared for what they knew was an
inevitable conflict Christian was
conscripted into the military and
Katherine returned to her father her
brother joins them fairly quickly after
he was - mobilized in 1940 and here
again their lives intertwine they grew
vegetables helped supplements the
meagerness of wartime supplies and made
regular excursions into can where they
were kept apprised of all that was going
on in the war they were on the outskirts
of the conflict but they would not stay
there for very long on June the 14th
1940 the day that so many Parisian
businesses had been preparing for
finally happened suddenly the city was
under a strict 8:00 p.m. curfew and
German troops were announcing the
official occupation an estimated two
million people had already left head of
the impending invasion and for those
that remained life was complicated
Parisians needed to find a way to
coexist with their occupiers and some
like Paris's other world famous fashion
designer Coco Chanel decided the best
way to get through the war was to
collaborate with the German military she
dated a high-ranking member of the abbé
there moved into the Paris Hotel Ritz
and was given her own codename as she
used the ongoing persecution of the Jews
to negotiate some business deals
Katharine and Christian Dior did the
opposite in 1941
Christian headed back to Paris leaving
his sister at kalyan he secured a
position at the fashion house a flew
ssin long and long did an incredible
thing even as Nazi officers informed him
they were going to be moving all of
Paris's fashion industry to Berlin long
first argued that it just wasn't
possible to move the thousands of
skilled artisans to another city you
couldn't retrain them either as it took
a decades to become skillful less his
employees work so he argued fashion
needed to stay in Paris Germany relented
the fashion industry remained in Paris
and along saved thousands of industry
workers many of whom were Jewish
refugees even as Christian established
himself in the industry as one of Long's
most valued employees Katharine was back
in kalyan it was the same year she did a
seemingly innocuous thing that would
change her life it was November of 1941
and she went shopping for a radio in a
store in kanne it was on that path
the ordinary shopping trip that she met
a man that she would fall in love with
his name was Herve - our Benari hence he
came with well a bit of baggage he was
married at the time - the mother of his
three children Lucy who was rumored to
have plenty of affairs of her own didn't
matter though not when it came to
blossoming love between her and the
young Katherine it was more than a
simple wartime fling though he and
Katherine didn't just fall in love they
joined a British sponsored section of
the French Resistance it was called the
famille or f2 and it was a cooperative
intelligence network that had been set
up by French and polish intelligence
officers in the summer of 1940 with a
bit of help from the British she
officially joined on July the 1st 1943
just a few months after Lucy it was
dangerous work it was the first branch
of the French Resistance devoted to
gathering intelligence and they were
doing it under the nose of a Vichy
government so sympathetic to the Nazi
cause of extermination that they didn't
just comply with the Nazis they went
above and beyond to identify members of
their Jewish population
Katherine became an intelligence agent
with the massive central units most of
her work was gathering and passing along
information on the movements of
Germany's troops and weapons reports
were sent to London to the Allies and to
the Troops who were under the command of
General de Gaulle Katherine now 29 years
old but looking a decade younger spent
much of her time on her bicycle
attracting the sort of attention a
pretty young girl riding along through
the French countryside would tend to get
from the men that she cycled past it was
nearly an ideal cover and it allowed her
to travel throughout the area fairly
freely when she was in Paris she would
often stay with her brother at his
apartment and even as close as they were
it's unclear whether or not she ever
told him what she was doing it was after
all the sort of thing he was better off
not knowing about especially considering
he spent his days designing dresses for
the wives of the Third Reich safety was
of course first and foremost and if she
didn't tell him it was a secret
she kept to protect him the stakes were
high and to say what she was doing was a
matter of life and death is no
exaggeration in later memoirs Katherine
would remember one day in particular
that she met her friends and fellow
resistance member Lily and died Lynne in
a cafe she hopped off her bike and
hugged her friends tightly enough that
dylon remembered that moments even 35
years later
asked Catherine about it and Catherine
remembered too she had delivered four
messages that day three in the morning
one in the afternoon eight people had
been arrested most would be tortured and
all would be executed when asked if
there were many days like that she
responded with a sad shrug and simply
said oh we it wasn't just the enemy they
knew about either by the middle of 1944
counterintelligence officers loyal to
the Germans and to the Vichy government
had infiltrated F - suddenly no one
could be trusted hundreds of French
Resistance agents were arrested torture
was common and Catherine would have seen
the bodies of her allies recovered from
where they had been dumped in the
streets July was a particularly bad
month dozens of agents were arrested
including
Jean de bourree who went by the codename
to rock he was taken on July the 5th and
held for four days of torture before his
body was recovered he had been beaten to
death his eyes torn from his head
Catherine was arrested on July the 6th
now this is all pretty intense so let's
just take a quick break for a moment and
talk about today's sponsor now in
today's video we're talking about
someone who carries the name of one of
the most iconic brands in the world and
you know what establishes a strong
identity and brand these days well
that's a beautiful personal website or a
business website and you can do that
with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful online identity maybe you're
like me you need a place on the web for
people to find you or maybe you're
starting a new business and you need to
set up an online presence or store well
you should do it with Squarespace on
Squarespace it all starts with a
stunning template instance with names
like Pursuit and Royce you know they're
particularly cool I mean seriously they
are great-looking templates or if you
hate beautiful templates and you know
I'm not judging you can start from
scratch maybe you've got mad design
skills
Squarespace make it super easy to make
something that looks amazing
you can also just easily move over from
an existing domain and if you've hosted
a web site elsewhere well you're gonna
find out it's a lot easier to manage
everything when you're on Squarespace
and once you've gone through the super
easy customization process there's no
updates there are no patches
there's no tech vs to deal with no one
likes any of that stuff
it's just simple with Squarespace and
look Squarespace it's not just about
having an online presence if you want to
you can also sell things you can run an
online store with Squarespace
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
forward slash playa graphics and you'll
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring and let's get
back to today's video
[Music]
when she showed up in Trocadero square
she thought she was keeping an
appointment she had made with a
colleague in the resistance Network
instead she was met by police under the
direction of a German French Foreign
Legion veteran named Friedrich bhaga
bhaga had set up a base for his
operations in a wealthy Parisian
neighborhood and his unit of
intelligence officers were known for
such brutal torture that allied officers
estimated that the longest their most
hardened well trained operatives could
hold out was just 24 hours catherine was
in custody for several weeks and when
other prisoners were asked what had
happens behind the closed doors at 180
Rue de la pomp they said she had never
broken burgers unit was so efficient at
uncovering French Resistance members
that it wasn't long before Catherine
needed to be moved to another secure
holding facility to await transport to a
final destination on July the 27th she
was taken to nearby friend prison and
this is really a case of a few days
making all the difference in the world
Berger and his men would flee Paris on
August the 17th and before they left
they shot and killed the 44 prisoners
that they were holding Christian
meanwhile heard about his sister's
arrest even with the contacts it made
through the fashion house he wasn't able
to get anyone to help secure her release
until it was too late on August the 15th
just 10 days before the liberation of
Paris Catherine was forced onto a hot
overcrowded train with more than 600
other women their final destination was
Germany and in this case time was not on
her side Christian had succeeded in
getting through to the Swedish consul
general located in Paris and they were
willing to speak to the Germans on how
the half RAL Nordling had already made
some impressive strides he had already
convinced German authorities not to
carry out Hitler's orders to destroy the
city and he had secured to the transfer
of political prisoners into Swedish
custody and Catherine dear was very
nearly included in that deal she was on
the train carrying a suffocating stench
of death that was so strong the gods
riding on the roof couldn't stand it
Nordling got permission to get her off
the train as long as he could get a
phone call through to the SS officers
when they stopped at the station in Bar
leduc but he couldn't get through and
the train kept on going catherine was
routed to ravensbrück web she was
examined her head was shaved
she was tattooed with the number 5 7 1 8
our a and given a uniform with the
inverted red triangle that denoted her
as a political prisoner Catherine never
freely spoke of her time in the custody
of the Nazis and it's not surprising the
atrocities of ravensbrück perhaps aren't
as well known as those of camps like
Auschwitz a sad fact that historians say
as a result of the camps location in
what became East Germany as well as the
fact that it was for women and not
nearly as well publicized when it was
liberated but it was no less horrible
more than 130,000 people were sent to
this camp according to best estimates
and surprisingly only about 26,000 were
Jewish others were political prisoners
like Catherine some were academics
deemed too dangerous to be allowed to
speak freely and some were simply sent
there for not conforming to the Nazi
ideals of race and femininity
ravensbrück was a work camp and
historians do know that catherine worked
at a number of nearby factories that
relied on slave labor sourced from the
camps she made explosives
torgul was forced to labor in a Prussian
salt mine and worked at a factory
building parts for aircraft she was also
part of a group that attempted to
sabotage production in those facilities
it's unclear whether or not a subterfuge
was ever discovered but sabotage was
common enough that there was a standard
punishment that anyone caught doing it
they would be sent to the bunker a
series of dark and suffocating cells
where troublemakers would be left to
languish away in solitary confinement of
course this was after the beatings and
whippings which had been approved by
Heinrich Himmler himself those that were
dishing out the punishments were very
good at it
ravensbrück was the training facility
for the female guards of the Nazi war
machine and some of the most notorious
women of the Third Reich got their start
that Irma Grese
later renamed the hyena of Auschwitz was
already gone by the time Kathryn arrived
but Dorothea bints who would later stand
trial for crimes like murder and setting
her dogs on the prisoners she was still
there conditions would dismal Katherine
was just one of the countless women who
were given nothing but rags to wear
offered nowhere near enough to eat and
as the blizzards and bitter cold winds
of winter descended it quickly became
clear that the dangerous conditions of
the factories and their disease ridden
lodgings were not the only dangers that
they faced Albert
of tuberculosis and dysentery were
common and so worth the medical
experiments polish prisoners were known
as rabbits and were often maimed to
simulate battlefield injuries most and
survive a gas chamber was built there in
February of 1945 and thousands had
already died there by April an adjacent
camp Orca mark was built for the olds
the ill the weak and as an execution
grounds for those found guilty of
espionage Katherine however was already
gone by the time their fellow prisoners
began to be sent to the gas chambers
she and a small group of French
prisoners were transferred out of
ravensberg in February 1945 they were
herded onto freezing cattle trucks and
stayed there with no heat no food and no
water for several days until they
reached marklar back there they found
they were going to be subjected to an
all-new sort of hell hard outdoor work
and temperatures that dipped well below
freezing she stayed there for months
until new orders were handed down on
Friday the 13th of April 1945 it was
just weeks before ravensbrück would be
liberated by a Soviet army who had fined
just 3,500 prisoners to let the camp the
others were all dead or like Katherine
told to start walking they were under
the watchful eye of SS officers who had
simple instructions shoot anyone who
tried to escape so they walked and
around 115 km/h that came to the city of
Dresden it lay in ruins it had been the
target of Allied bombers only a few
months before and even today no one is
sure of the death toll anywhere from 35
thousand to a hundred and thirty five
thousand people were dead and the city
that had once been called the Florence
of the Elbe had been destroyed by
thousands of tons of bombs and
incendiaries that had set off a
firestorm that had engulfed military
targets railways museums and civilian
homes with equal enthusiasm walking into
the smoldering ruins of a city that had
once been one of Europe's most beautiful
destinations had to be heartbreaking but
still Katherine somehow managed to slip
away from the group take shelter among
the ruins and hide until the SS had
marched away on April the 19th a week
after she had been marched out of
markleham park she was found by a group
of American soldiers she was still near
the bombed out ruins of Dresden and when
they took her to a hospital for care she
would be there for the next month
meanwhile Christian had gotten word that
her name had been discovered on a list
of
raishin can prisoners but it wasn't
clear where she was if she had been
among those liberated or if she had been
among the dead in an odd twist he
received that message on April the 19th
as well for weeks the only assurances he
had that he would once again see his
beloved sister came from the
clairvoyance that he regularly consulted
Madame's Ella he had been unwavering in
her insistence that Katherine would
return from Germany and it wasn't until
May the 27th that he got another message
one that said she was indeed coming home
Katherine was back home in Paris the day
after her brother got the message
telling him that she was alive and she
was one of the many on a train of
refugees bound for Paris she was a
shadow of a former self emaciated unable
to eat solid foods and suffering from
what we now call PTSD she wasn't just
reunited with her brother also waiting
to greet her was curved a sharpener a
and his children based on the accounts
of friends they put their lives back
together bills her family of their own
and Katherine was allowed to live on in
something that they described as
relative peace while she rarely talked
about what she went through during her
imprisonment she did testify at a
military tribunal in 1952 and as a
strange sort of footnote to that
Friedrich Berger didn't stand trial for
his actions in breaking up the French
Resistance by torture and murder he had
been captured by British forces and was
eventually handed over to the Americans
and he went on to work with the Secret
Service as for Katherine her work in the
resistance and her bravery in the face
of torture was recognised she was
awarded a slew of medals including the
quarter ger the combatants volunteer
Cross of the resistance the combatants
cross and from Britain the Kings medal
for courage in the cause of freedom she
was also named a Chevalier of the légion
zarnow and of course Christian would
name his first perfume for her just two
years after her return to Paris and she
stayed busy she became their
representative in cut flowers and for
more than a decade Sheehan hive would
arrive at the palace Marcus at 4:00 a.m.
to set up their display of cut flowers
brought into the city of lights from all
over the world
she and her have continued to live
together until his death in 1985 and for
years she faithfully attended an annual
memorial service for members of the
French Resistance even throughout up
later years she
steadfast in her support for the cause
that she had nearly given her life for
she publicly distanced herself from the
more controversial members of her family
including her niece Francois who
publicly declared herself a neo-nazi
when she married British extremist
leader Colin Jordan in a ceremony that
involved a copy of Hitler's Mein Kampf
Christian Dior died in 1957 and
afterwards her van Catherine moved back
to kalyan where it all started
she grew roses destined for inclusion in
the perfume that her brother had named
her for and went on to help establish
the do museum in the Grand ville home
that they had grown up in she never
returned to Germany but passed away in
2008 so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
give it a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe also great way to
support what we're doing here at
biographic says to support our sponsors
like Squarespace who I'm linking to you
below and thank you for watching
[Music]